> TOPPING OUR WORLD LEAD,
PUTIN JUST HIT THE GAS.
TODAY HE TOLD HIS NEWLFORMED
COORDINATION COUNCIL THEY NE
TO SPEED UP DECISION MAKING AND
MANUFACTURING TO WIN THE BLOODY
WAR HE CALLS A SPECIAL
OPERATION.
IT COMES AS UKRAINE'S MILITARY
TOUTS A POTENTIAL RETREAT OF
RUSSIAN FORCES NEAR THE KEY
SOUTHERN CITY OF KHERSON.
CNN'S FRED PLEITGEN REPORTS ITS
MEMBERS ARE CONFIDENT THEY'RE
ONE STEP CLOSER TO TAKING BACK
THAT SHINING CITY IN THE SOUTH.
>> Reporter: EN ROUTE TO THE
FRONT IN ONE OF THE MOST ACTIVE
AREAS OF THE BRUTAL WAR IN
UKRAINE WITH A ROCKET ARTILLERY
TEAM TAKING AIM AT VLADIMIR
PUTIN'S FORCES.
THEY'RE CALLED CARLSON AND USE
LIGHT TRUCKS WITH MISSILE PODS
MOUNTED ON THE BED.
THE ROCKETS CARRY A MESSAGE OF
RETRIBUTION.
THIS ONE SIGNED ON BEHALF OF A
FALLEN SOLDIER, FROM THE WITCH,
IT SAYS.
>> Translator: OUR VEHICLE IS
VERY EFFECTIVE BECAUSE WE CAN
SET UP QUICKLY, FIRE, AND GET
AWAY AGAIN.
>> Reporter: NOW THEY'RE AIMING
AT RUSSIAN POSITIONS SEVERAL
MILES AWAY.
BUT RUSSIA'S ARTILLERY IS ALSO
DANGEROUS AND COULD FIRE BACK
FAST.
IT'S NOT SAFE, HE SCREAMS.
WE HAVE TO GET OUT OF HERE AS
FAST AS POSSIBLE BECAUSE THE
RUSSIANS MIGHT TARGET THIS
POSITION AFTER THEY GET HIT BY
THE SALVO FROM OUR ROCKETS.
THEIR KEY TO ACCURACY COMES FROM
THE AIR.
THE DRONE SCOPES OUT THE TARGET
AND THEN WATCHES AS THE
ARTILLERY HITS A RUSSIAN
MILITARY REPAIR SHOP, THE UNIT
SAYS.
>> Translator: WE ARE THE EYES
AND DID RECONNAISSANCE MAKING
SURE THE TARGET IS HIT.
>> Reporter: THEY'VE STARTED
EVACUATING TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE FROM KHERSON AND THE
UKRAINIANS BELIEVE MOSCOW IS
MAKING ITS UNFOUNDED CLAIMS
ABOUT PREPARING TO USE A
SO-CALLED DIRTY BOMB BECAUSE
RUSSIA'S TROOPS ARE PINNED DOWN
IN THIS AREA.
THE COMMANDER BELIEVES IT'S ONLY
A MATTER OF TIME BEFORE THEY
OUST VLADIMIR PUTIN'S ARMY FROM
HERE.
>> Translator: BY THE END OF THE
YEAR WE BELIEVE KHERSON WILL BE
UNDER UKRAINIAN FLAGS.
>> Reporter: AND THEY HOPE THEIR
UNIT WILL MAKE A SMALL
DIFFERENCE IN THE BATTLE FOR
KHERSON.
IT CERTAINLY SEEMS LIKE ONE OF
THE MOST ACTIVE REGIONS IN THIS
BLOODY WAR GOING ON IN UKRAINE.
WE SPENT A GOOD AMOUNT OF TIME
IN KHERSON AND REALLY THE ENTIRE
TIME WE WERE THERE, JOHN, WE
COULD HEAR THE THUDS OF
ARTILLERY AND ROCKETS BEING
EXCHANGED THERE.
THEY SAY THEY ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT SOME OF THE RHETORIC
COMING OUT OF MOSCOW WITH
ALLEGATIONS ABOUT A DIRTY BOMB.
THE FOREIGN MINISTER OF UKRAINE
SAYING HE BELIEVES THE FACT THE
RUSSIANS ARE SO PERVASIVE AND
KEEP UTTERING THOSE ALLEGATIONS
SHOWS THE RUSSIANS MAY BE
PLANNING A FALSE FLAG OPERATION.
>> WHAT A PERSPECTIVE.
WHAT A WINDOW YOU GAVE US IN